good morning guys today's a beach day
yes yes yes yes yes isaac's upstairs
that's why he's not joining in the
celebration because he's trying to get
his last five minutes in
of pc gaming oh yeah
next week so today's saturday all right
next week he has a whole
week left true summer break summer break
he's going back to school so we're
winding down
summer break we are living it up because
the next week we're doing jk news so
like jk newsweek is pretty much all
gone and it's like a real work week so
yeah this is our last
week yeah we get one week on one week
off but before we go to the beach i
wanted to talk about our new beach
things that we have ordered online
and they are here we're still missing
the canopy the pop-up canopy thing to
provide shade but what do we got we got
a picnic table
we have a table we haven't pulled this
out i know can we build it
no i haven't built it yet let's build it
see what happens when we do this
wait we gotta read the instructions
you're not an instructions person huh
in the last video the pizza video that
me and isaac are making pizza we're
going step by step and not reading ahead
like all the instructions
construction at a time and we missed
things we did obviously
you you would have failed that one test
that the teacher gives where
where at the end of the thing it says
only write your name and that's it wait
you're still gonna not read the test
growing up instructions
i always felt like that was a trick
question it was not a
reflection of how smart anyone was it is
because smart people
think ahead smart people think ahead you
know what's funny
i know i'm giving you so much crap for
not reading instructions and
i don't see the instructions in here
i think i threw it away okay we'll
figure it out
this is my hand no instructions
i saw this on amazon and i'm like oh
because we need like a portable table or
whatever yeah this is actually really
small
they do have a large but they sold out
of the large so i got
the small one i was like would you build
the chair too
you just said i sat down out of nowhere
what are you sitting behind
like an aladdin and he jumps off the
balcony
are you sitting on air so i like it
for like camping yeah i don't think
we'll need it today true most of this
stuff is also for camping like the beach
stuff it
doubles for camping stuff as well the
other thing
we got this one i'm not gonna extend and
i'll just show you when we're at the
beach but it's a new beach blanket
yeah and over here like this one does
come with instructions
let's get rid of the warnings oh what's
this for what's that for
for the table genius wife what do we do
i don't know where does it go
genius wife it's not broken i just
popped out oh
you're right you're so genius okay g-dub
oh that was really easy so we got a new
wagon
look at those beefy wheels too i know
we're going off-roading with these guys
so we're gonna put the cooler in here
all of our chairs do we need to bring
this today i'm just think so
yeah because i don't really need a table
so we're bringing this guy
this guy goes in here yep let's go
all right we have to fold it back up now
all right so we packed up all the things
we put them in the car
we're ready to go to the beach but
before we go to the beach i want to give
a huge shout out to our sponsor
brightsellers
the monthly wine club so a few days ago
i ended up doing this wine quiz and they
asked me questions like what's your
favorite kind of candy and then there
was reese's peanut butter cups there so
i clicked on that and then
they just made me go through all these
different questions and at the end of it
they paired me up with wines that would
match my taste buds which i am
absolutely ecstatic and i really really
want to try these winds up and so
they sent me a box with six wine bottles
which i'm super excited for because
usually i'm not the wine person in this
relationship here
this guy is the wine guy and
i always say so a few days ago when when
we got this opportunity i was like oh
casey can i please take the wine quiz
because you are very adventurous when it
comes to wines i'm very
conservative i guess i don't know i just
i haven't found a lot of wines that
really tickle me but uh forget your
fancies yes
exactly pinky out and all that stuff and
so i took the quiz they sent me
six bottles here you can see the there's
three on the top but actually
there's one missing you know why because
in these wine education cards that they
give us
with each wine they end up educating you
and so they describe the tasting notes
for example like blueberry plum
vanilla chocolate and they also give you
the suggested
serving temperature so for this
particular bottle that i'm really
excited to
taste i put in the freezer it recommends
serving temperatures for
full red put it in the freezer for five
minutes and then we're gonna
taste it because i'm really excited i
wanna see like oh did they actually get
my taste bud preferences correct let's
find out
nice and chilled so we're gonna try out
lost city like i said this one comes
from argentina
mendoza argentina and this is pretty
cool because they they even allow you to
rate the wine
rating the wine is really good because
it ends up fine tuning
your future wine matches so i'm really
excited to just do my
own little wine tasting at home and i
get to
give feedback and then find out which
ones are gonna be better for my taste
buds in the future
oh that's my favorite every time do you
get the
blueberry the chocolate yeah it smells
good oh you're
just like with isaac every time he's
pretending to be our waiter he he does
that thing
so cute just don't don't stain the
thing oh yeah do you like to
taste aerated let me aerate it
that's good i like the technique you got
there i like it
usually with wines things that have
alcohol in it they always make me
like make a certain face this did not
make me make any sort no no
no no no no nasal i do something weird
like this every time i don't like the
flavor of anything
you didn't see that face come out of me
that's delicious okay this wine is
really good
and i'm really shocked because like i
said before i'm
picky when it comes to alcohol
particularly with wine
the fact that this wine came out so
delicious is really making me excited to
try out
the rest of the five bottles that i have
here and if you want to get your own
six bottle box make sure to go to the
description right now
click on that link take your wine quiz
and get half
off your first six bottle block but in
the meantime we gotta go to the beach
and we can't take this with us because
that's illegal
but when we get back home we're gonna be
popping some bottles
wow what a view welcome to the beach
mask required
yeah there's like little sand pockets
here we go we made it
yay shade oh yes that's
perfect yeah right it literally landed
right on me
look at this amazing perfect hi
ray yes hi ray
you want to hold it go for it cheese
this is so nice it is very nice very
nice
you guys are enjoying the sun you're
wearing your wetsuit okay
oh snap you know it's really awesome so
dee
has a wetsuit that fits her too small so
i ended up trying it on it fits me
really really tight but i think that's
how wetsuits are supposed to fit and i'm
really eager
to try it out in the actual water
but it's such a pain in the butt to put
it on it's like oh my god it's like
peeling skin
onto yourself like that's how tight it
is it almost feels like the circulation
is getting cut off and then once she's
done i'll try it on
oh really you're gonna put it on after
me yeah all sandy and
what yeah man it's probably gonna be
harder for you
but you could try see how it works out
it's currently four o'clock so the sun
is not like
layering on us and it just feels really
nice right now
feel the water wow actually i forgot to
mention to you guys but where we live
it was 110 degrees it took us an hour
to drive out to their house and they
live like 10 minutes away from this
beach
must be nice man so when we got to their
place it was like 85 degrees or
something or 89 or something like that
but from 110 to 89 it's like it's
obviously a huge difference so it just
feels so much nicer
yes chinkatara yeah it does look like
italy over there
pretty cool because we actually went to
italy with them we did a whole italy
like backpacking through italy i think
we went to like seven cities or
something it was really fun this was
like back in
2013 i think 2014 how long we've been
friends
actually longer than that
oh that's chilly that water is chilly
it's gonna be good to try it on with the
wetsuit
oh
okay so this wet boot
is really interesting because
my body feels warm still in this cold
water but then it's also a little bit
cold because some of the water is going
through
it's weird nice too i wonder where
i don't know i think it's unicycle watch
out
let's hold on my glasses you know it's
weird like the water kind of goes inside
the suit a little bit so then
i could feel like cold a little bit but
this little car is really
oh hi andrew how's it feel
it feels weird but it feels really cool
though the water going yeah
i like it a lot so that water will get
warm whatever's going inside i can feel
it
that's adjusting to my body temperature
really quickly so it makes me feel
really warm
you're not cold i mean you're from
california you're used to it you used to
cold water i'm from virginia where it's
warm
is it in the summertime yeah i've never
known
l.a water's too warm i don't know i
didn't know that too when i moved out
here i was like i got in the water i was
like
freezing yeah i was like you mean you
guys don't go in the water
i don't know it's all the lie that
california dream yeah
it's alive it is cold right there
oh yeah that was a nice place yeah you
made it out
you made it it's really cold oh yeah
oh yeah boy
how is it isaac worse than putting on
like a tight shoe yes way worse
like you have your claustrophobic what
weird
oh weird it's always the butt
part i got it
wow look at you we're the same person
man
yeah i'm just like slightly bigger than
you but
i'm amazed that we fit into the same
thing now
so when you get in the water it doesn't
feel like anything
this feels like you're getting splat by
something
you want to ride it it's fine the water
is getting in there
it's supposed to you feel it getting in
yeah it's getting colder
yeah it will warm up some of these waves
are pretty good
all right i'm gonna go underwater now
so it's warming up oh there's another
big wave coming
what is going on over here
i got the shot
hmm